but there's a hint of kind of an Indian
accent underneath it all and you say
something like this song is only
dedicated to beautiful people here
tonight and as you can hear it only
dedicated to beautiful people here
tonight hearing the news that you'll be
playing Freddie Mercury is quite an
out-of-body experience doing the
research and talking to Brian May and
Roger Taylor of you're truly meeting
rock stars and then rock stars who are
going to in my mind judge at every
different nuance of me not only playing
Freddie Mercury but me as rami malek
so when I met them I tried to walk in
with a little hint of Freddie we I just
done this tape at Abbey Road
the previous night singing four songs
and trying to emulate Freddie as best I
could
having them watch it with me it was it
was very surreal and I almost forgot
that after the end of four songs one of
the writers in our producer were in the
sound booth and they just started firing
off questions and I was answering them
as Freddie and there was one moment
where they asked me the question who do
you trust the most Freddie and
[Music]
answer this I'm standing in between
these two men with which one did I pick
and there's well that would have to be
Mary Mary's the person that I trust the
most and I can said thank God I thank
God and you know they both come on so I
got out of that the way in into him for
me because it was going to be such a
monumental task as I thought try to
approach it in the way you would any
role where you look at you know the
human being and why they do everything
they do how they respond to things now
there was almost an immediacy for me to
get his voice you know when you you know
when you just kind of fall in love with
someone and you start picking up on
things almost immediately if I if I
really get along with someone I'll start
just kind of taking a little bit
I mean his family is Parsi and spoke
Gujarati then he got sent to boarding
school so he has this posh thing on top
of it but there's a hint of kind of an
Indian accent underneath it all he say
something like this song is only
dedicated to beautiful people here
tonight and you can hear it only
dedicated to beautiful people here
tonight but you know I'm very conscious
of never wanting to mimic him
here's a guy who says in his own words
I've had an upheaval of an upbringing
the name like Farouk al-shara
wasn't very easy at first with those
teeth it wasn't very easy with
struggling to identify his sexuality
that's difficult enough with those
circumstances just to make it and then
to persevere in and become one of the
most remarkable prolific artists of any
generation is an astounding feat of
accomplishment
you